[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
June 28th I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
can be frustrating and costly when
someone is told by their health
insurance company that a certain
treatment or procedure isn't covered
under their plan but many people don't
know the range of options they have to
appeal those decisions Wall Street
Journal reporter Anna wilda Matthews
joins us so Anna aside from the rising
monthly costs what are people's top
complaints about their health insurance
plans well people have a lot of gripes
about their health insurance plans there
was a recent survey from a non-profit
called kff and they found some of the
biggest complaints were that insurance
paid less than consumers expected for a
bill the insurance didn't cover care or
a drug that the patient got or the
insurance denied or delayed pre-approval
for a treatment that the patient wanted
the survey found that 58 of insured
adults had run into problems using their
health insurance just in the past year
how do people's health conditions work
into this the survey found that people
with more health conditions had more
gripes about their insurance
also about four in 10 people who said
that their mental health was fair or
poor said they hadn't been able to get a
medication or a service that they needed
when someone runs into a situation where
their insurance plan won't pay for
something many people just might accept
it and move on what do consumer
Advocates suggest that they do a lot of
people don't realize they actually have
an appeal process they don't realize
that there's something they can do when
the insurer declines to pay for
something but there definitely is
insurers all have an appeals process and
in addition to the internal appeals
process there's also the opportunity
ultimately to appeal to a third party so
what consumer Advocates told me is that
people should do that they should not
just give up they should definitely
fight and they might win so this is more
than just telling the person on the
phone hey can I talk to your manager
about this yeah absolutely what the
consumer Advocates told me is that a
phone call is a good first step but
definitely that's just the first step
when you call you should take notes you
should get the name of the person you're
talking to but that you probably want to
file a formal appeal and you'll
typically want to do that in written
form you'll also typically want to work
really closely with your doctor or your
hospital whoever provided the care or
maybe prescribed the drug they may
actually be better positioned to do the
first appeal for you or you can work
with them but you'll want them to
explain why this is care that's really
important to your health and why you
need it and it shouldn't be denied rules
are rules but you did mention that there
are several escalating steps here so
would being persistent pay off and how
often are appeals successful what I
heard from The Advocates is that yes
being persistent can pay off it doesn't
always you got to be realistic but it
can there are different levels of appeal
and ultimately it can go to an outside
third party and information about how to
do that should be given to you in any
letters you get from the insurer in
terms of the rate of success that's not
always closed it's not always clear and
it does vary but there was one study
that the federal office of Inspector
General for the Department of Health and
Human Services did that found that 75
percent of denials were overturned on
appeal for Medicare Advantage plans so
that's a pretty high number and it just
illuminates that yes appeals can work is
this a sort of situation where a
computer could misread someone's claim
in an actual person might overturn the
initial decision there are all sorts of
different ways things can be rejected
and that's why an initial phone call is
good and it's also why you want to work
with your doctor or hospital or the
health care provider who is involved
because you'll often find that those
entities have appealed many times before
and kind of know the ropes on how to do
it but you'll find that things can be
rejected because the health insurer says
it's not medically necessary so that
would be one thing like just don't think
this is a treatment you needed but they
can also reject things because it's not
a service that your plan covers that's a
different kind of rejection and that may
be more challenging in some ways as an
example there are decent number of
health plans that don't cover drugs for
weight loss so you see a lot of folks
out there these days seeking coverage
for the drugs that are similar to
ozempic would Govi in particular but
you'll find that some plans and Medicare
actually is included here just don't
cover drugs if you're trying to take it
for weight loss so if you're appealing
that that really can be sort of an
upwards battle and a harder thing to win
what are some examples of third parties
that could get involved in the appeals
process and how would they actually
assist in that process well it's
definitely helpful to seek out some kind
of help or an advocate the first step
there is often to go to your doctor's
office or the hospital whomever was
working with you to provide that care
because they may know the most but there
are also a lot of private and government
entities that might help a lot of states
have these operations called consumer
assistance programs a few examples for
instance Connecticut has one New York
has one and they can help people with
appeals and they do a lot of appeals in
their state so if you're in Medicare
there are these programs called State
Health Insurance Assistance programs
that specifically deal with Medicare
there are also non-profits like the
Patient Advocate Foundation that will
work with folks who need help on appeals
one good first step can be to call your
State Insurance regulator every state
does have one they don't always deal
with appeals themselves but they should
typically know the process and might be
able to help you understand it better
but when considering the appeals process
how much of the responsibility lies with
the consumer's knowledge of his or her
own policy honestly even before you come
to the point of needing to appeal
something it's really good to have
information and good background about
your policy so even before you seek the
care it might be good to figure out is
this something that's going to be
covered before you're fighting them on
the back end about something you thought
was covered so what consumer Advocates
told me is that you probably should have
the planned documents for your health
insurance just around right keep it
digitally someplace there's a document
called the summary of benefits and
coverage that's a good start and those
often have links to the more complete
explanation of your plan because people
don't always understand the ins and outs
of their plan that's one thing that we
found out from this kff survey people
don't really always know what their plan
covers and what they're going to have to
pay out of pocket and these plans can be
very very complicated that's Wall Street
Journal reporter Anna wielder Matthews
and that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]